hey michael this is camille i'm just
calling in because i have a question
about guys and girls mentality with
dating
so as a girl i have a very intense
moral hangover probably derived from a
lot of catholic guilt but it kind of
prevented me from engaging in my
quote-unquote whole years but i was
wondering if guys have that same type of
guilt
if they're in their player years not
just guilt for
what they're doing to girls if they're
not
dating them if they're just hooking up
with them but if they have any guilt of
just kind of living that more immoral
lifestyle of hookup culture
we'd love to hear your thoughts thanks
and love the show
love those phrases that i i realized i
did hear correctly when you said the men
have the player years and then i think
the first phrase you used was hoe years
for women so first thing
generally if you haven't already gone
through it probably good to avoid those
years
i know it's very easy i think a lot of
people fall into it obviously but you
know if you can avoid i wouldn't i
wouldn't aim
at having hoe years or player years
probably not that great your question
though do you do men
feel some shame and guilt from that the
answer is yes yeah
not just because you roll over on the
pillow and you look at the girl lying
next to you and you say oh why am i yes
why am i doing this not just because of
the girl
but because of you because you are
degrading yourself
because you are
when you pursue
women or men in that way
is just a vessel for your own pleasure
you are degrading yourself to the level
of an animal
you are a human being with intellect
with reason with virtue with integrity
with worth but you degrade yourself to
the level of an animal that just needs
to
be titillated when when you do that kind
of thing
and it reduces your view of the other
person too you're degrading the other
person and even if you have a crush on
the other person even if you think very
highly of the other person when you
engage in an act together that is
intrinsically shameful that will that
will lower your view of the other person
as well and it will diminish the
possibilities for a longer kind of love
affair with that person so yeah men have
it too
women men and women have it a little bit
differently because men and women
approach sex differently but men have it
too and men can get sex-osted and men
can feel that same kind of shame and
ideally that would be sooner rather than
later if they have to go through that at
all next question
howdy nostradamus my name is houston and
my question is about a topic that has
come up when discussing religion among
my peers
i've grown closer to the church while in
college both thanks to you and my study
group here's the thing i listen to a lot
of metal but not just any type
specifically death metal
i understand that some of the lyrics are
blasphemous but i'm far more captivated
by the intricacies of the instruments
which makes sense since i play guitar
myself both for a band and a church
is it possible to be practicing
christian while also enjoying and
performing this type of music
if not couldn't the same be said for the
modern degeneracy that kids are
listening to now i've been told that as
long as i don't feel conviction i'm okay
would love to hear your thoughts on this
thanks a sworthy breakfast taco
[Laughter]
really really good question and i'm
going to give you a really really hard
answer
yeah you probably shouldn't listen to
that
i'm sorry i don't want to be a wet
blanket it's not even just the lyrics i
mean obviously you shouldn't listen to
music that is blasphemous but you can
find metal you can find extremely
hardcore metal that is not overtly
blasphemous that's not even the main
issue
the main issue with
death metal is the is the music actually
it's more the percussion plato has this
point which is he
he observes that
more than anything else it's music and
rhythm even especially that
that can transform your soul
in that it bypasses your reason when
you're listening to music especially
music that's very percussive especially
music that's very
uh bee-boppy you know or in the case of
death metal you know it's all just like
when
when you listen to that you're not
reasoning about it you're not sitting
back like you're listening to i don't
know a symphony by bach and thinking
about it and thinking in a in a really
calm way about it
and and even then you know
even more classical music will bypass
your reason to a large degree but when
you're listening to very percussive
stuff it will totally bypass your reason
and it will transform your soul it will
take the strongest hold upon your soul
as plato says and so you've got to be
aware of that
i'm not saying you can never listen to
death metal again but
but i wouldn't recommend it
i wouldn't recommend it i would
recommend
i would recommend generally avoiding
things
that take you totally out of your reason
and when you're in a mosh pit just or
you're listening to death metal or
something like that you are out of your
reason when you drink
three bottles of whiskey you're going to
be out of your reason too and you don't
you don't
want to do that sorry to be a wet
blanket not saying you have to totally
tune out all the death metal immediately
but i think as you
as you grow in your spiritual life you
you will naturally
uh pull away from that kind of music and
pursue other kinds of tastes sorry sorry
to say i'm sorry
to rain on your parade but that's just
the way it is i'm sorry that i have to
plato pill you but that's the way it
goes next question
hello michael this is tony fauci
i wanted to call and let you know that i
am deeply disappointed
in the disinformation that you've been
spreading on your show
and i wanted to tell you to tell all of
your sheep to wear the mask
your sheep need to wear the mask my
question is this do you really think
elon musk is gonna buy twitter
if so
i might just have to retire early
thanks and remember to wear the donut
michael just wear the donut
you're not the real tony fauci i'm the
tony foggy no you're the tony fudgy
which one do i which one do i go for i
don't i know that was an excellent
it was a really excellent dr fauci
impression or you just are tony fauci to
your question
is elon musk gonna buy twitter right now
it looks like he is not i actually did
have a friend of mine who from the very
beginning of the elon twitter
saga said elon doesn't really want to
buy twitter he just wants an excuse to
sell tesla stock at all-time highs it's
the same thing as when
elizabeth warren complained that he
didn't pay enough taxes and elon did a
twitter poll where he said he was going
to sell a bunch of tesla and then he
would have to pay taxes on it
my friend viewed that as another kind of
ruse just to be able to sell tesla at
very high prices uh so it could be that
uh it also the other option is this
could be a way for elon musk to try to
get a better deal on twitter but i don't
know if i were a gambling man today i
would say elon does not buy twitter and
it was all just a really funny troll
which is fine by me i really enjoyed the
troll i got a real kick out of it and if
elon got to make a little bit of money
on it all the better though it may
backfire he may end up having to spend a
lot of money uh to get out of the
twitter deal all of that remains to be
seen but either way we all got a bunch
of lols out of it so i think it was
worthwhile next voice mailbag question
mr nostradamus i am smiling sam uh i am
a blue checkmart athlete i've been in
the ufc for a number of years i and i'm
one of those guys that thinks lebron and
people like that should shut up and
dribble
so i've kind of held myself to that same
principle i will shut up and punch
now my question for you is
should i keep doing that i have a topic
that i won't i will not hold my tongue
on abortion i am a foster parent i have
six children i have adopted one and i'm
going to continue adopting children
until they are all mine uh and they are
all very loved uh
other than that though i tend to keep my
mouth shut because like i said earlier
i'm a big fan of the shut up and dribble
thing
they aren't
should i be fighting fire with fire
should i be using all the power that
comes with my little blue check mark to
try and fight back to try and reassure
others that i'm with them or should i
not uh
i appreciate it also i live in nashville
i would love to have you and your family
out for uh barbecue one of these days
anyways keep up the good work my friend
and thank you for the advice that sounds
great thank you for the invitation would
love to do it and thank you for the
question very good question
should you use the great power and
responsibility of the blue check and
voice your opinions
perhaps
to some degree
my advice here is it's not an all or
nothing kind of thing
you don't need to either keep your mouth
totally shut or
have the maga hat on doing jumping jacks
constantly you're very lucky that you're
in the ufc which is probably the most
conservative sports league there is in
the country right now so you'll get a
little grace for that anyway
but as you say i won't keep my mouth
shut on abortion you could
be judicious and prudent about the ways
that you speak up you're not a
politician you're not
hold you don't hold a public office so
you don't have to speak up on lots of
these different issues you certainly can
but perhaps you pick your battles
perhaps you do it in a way that's a
little
subtler you know you do it through
retweets you do it through posting hey i
listen to this i really liked this you
do this through weighing in in a way
that maybe has a little bit of a lighter
touch you're very
known for a tougher touch
in ufc so maybe you try a little bit of
a lighter touch in politics i think that
can be really
charming and effective if you're a
little bit winsome and witty about these
things so i would
i would maybe lean into that it doesn't
have to be an all or nothing owning the
libs is much more an art than a science
great question right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast you're getting pinched right now
everything that you buy is getting more
expensive with one exception your cell
phone plan if you switch to pure talk
what are you spending on your cell phone
bill probably
60 70 i don't know 80 or 90 bucks a
month you can cut that by two-thirds if
you switch to puretalk right now
puretalk gives you talk text plenty of
data for just 30 per month no price
increase there no byte inflation
affecting that i am a puretalk customer
i love puretalk it's incredibly reliable
i use puretalk a lot for my job i use
puretalk for my personal life the 5g
coverage is great plus they make the
switch from your current provider
incredibly easy won't take you more than
10 minutes which is amazing well worth
the savings 10 minutes definitely well
worth saving 60 bucks a month right now
our listeners by the way in addition to
that are saving 50 off their first month
when they use promo code noel's podcast
at puretalk.com hard to depend on the
government hard to depend on this crazy
economy you can depend on pure talk
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code now's podcast say 50 off your first
month switch over in less than 10
minutes puretalk.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
all one word i'm so glad that you like
that clip you know we just hit 1 million
subscribers here on youtube thank you to
everyone who made that happen let's push
it up even higher next goal 1 billion so
please subscribe like ring the bell
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you